[Music]
evan's with us in winston-salem hi evan
welcome to the ramsey show
hi dave how are you better than i
deserve what's up
um well me and my wife uh we're on baby
step 3b trying to stay for a house and
uh we've got a chance to buy a house
um from a family member um she's my
wife's cousin
and uh not really like a close family
but they're offering it to us at um 3.5
interest on a 15-year fixed rate owner
financing
and i've called around to the banks the
best that i can do is probably around
four
or a little over four and so we me and
my wife were longtime listeners and we
just wasn't sure
about owner finance center if that was a
safe thing to do
owner financing is as safe as anything
else if you have a good attorney draft
they equip draft the uh documents it's
not a land contract it's an actual
mortgage and the deed of the house goes
into your name
yes okay there's no land contracts at
all we don't do those okay now the
downside of the whole scenario you're
giving the the other the other upside is
you're going to have a lot less costs
involved closing costs
other things that you're going to not
have with owner financing so that part's
all wonderful
how often do you have dinner with this
cousin
uh this is the first time that we've
spoken to them and
probably at their wedding about 10 years
ago maybe okay so you never see them
you're not mad at them but you just it's
not a relationship you have
no it's this is not one that we have
okay because here's the thing it's going
to affect whatever relationship you have
the borrower is slave to the lender
when you borrow money from someone you
change your relationship from cousin to
master
yep
okay and so if you're if your
father-in-law loans you this money i
would tell you no
because thanksgiving dinner tastes
different when you eat with your master
it will change the tone the relationship
of your between you and your wife your
her dad all that kind of stuff never do
that one
but this one is really there's not much
of a relationship here this is almost
like a stranger
yes and so i'm probably doing it
okay
i agree um
it's another one evan in in like just
the in
in most of the calls though when it
comes to borrowing money from family
it's just an absolute no uh but there's
these exceptions like this this is
distance yeah where it's so distant and
it's like
there's not really you're not going to
be with them you're not seeing them
every day you guys aren't chatting and
talking and there's not really much of a
relationship to hinder because there's
not much of a relationship so so in that
makes
nobody's mad we're not saying no no but
it's just you know the thing is if it
absolutely completely went bad and went
sideways and everybody was mad it really
wouldn't change your life
right yeah and we're not calling that
we're not saying that's going to happen
but the the point being
that you know if you borrow from your
father-in-law that that would you lose
that relationship or a sibling or an
in-law i mean yeah somebody
said you're spending time with yeah
but um like rachel's got cousins that
she actually has really tight
relationships with
right that you would not do this you
would not do this deal with them
yeah
not a chance i'm not changing because
i'm telling you man the old joke is if
you loan your brother-in-law 100 and he
never speaks to you again was it worth
it right i mean you know
so
because it does change the relationship
when you loan or borrow money it just
does so but the point being here is
there's not much of a relationship to
change so that's i'm doing it because
it's a cheaper interest rate saves money
make sure you have an attorney close the
deal like you would any other
professional transaction get title
insurance get an inspection on the house
get an appraisal on the house all of
those kinds of things you would do if
you're doing a normal transaction
to where you know one's getting screwed
here no one's that's all very
business-like and button-up all the
documents are done they're properly
filed at the courthouse a title company
does the closing you do everything right
here if you do all that right you're
going to have lowered cost and lowered
interest rate and it's a good deal go
get it